Speaker 1: A we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P.
You can call that number. Absolutely. Any time
you want you you want to call it four a.m. like
many people do. Go ahead. Here is a voicemail
just reminding us, you know, this question of do
Trump supporters believe the stuff that's being
said about the election or not? And Seinfeld is
instructive in. Listening to take a listen to this
Speaker 5: point anyway, David,
I wanted to, by the way,
Speaker 1: a classic is the caller
doesn't pause the show. They call while my voice
is playing in the background that's going on here.
Speaker 5: Now that as we've all learned from our
friend George Costanza. Right. That it's not a lie
if you believe it. And I'm hearing you
struggle right now on your broadcast. Yeah,
well, the spokesperson for Trump is able to
discern the truth from a delusion. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Yes. I mean, I think
it's just the line from Seinfeld,
but I think it actually is instructive. It's not
a lie if you believe it. And many of these people
certainly have drank the Kool-Aid. And that's an
appropriate term, given that given the cultlike
nature of Trump and followers and acolytes, we
have a great bonus show for you today. Now we're
going to talk about Wal-Mart offering tuition
for employees. Is it is it a real, genuine thing?
Is it a marketing ploy or is it both? We will
also talk about a federal judge forcing an accused
capital writer to unlock their laptop with facial
recognition and what this means for the future of
such investigations and full mandatory masking.
Returning to the state of Nevada, people told
to avoid Las Vegas like the plague, although
I don't even know if, like the plague has the
same meaning now, since many people didn't seem
that into avoiding it. All of those stories and
more on today's bonus show. Don't miss it. Sign up
at Join Pakman Dotcom and we will speak to that.